深感    失望
我们每一个人在人生的旅途当中
都会遇到让自己感到愤怒受伤
甚至是怨恨的事
生活中
常常会有那些令我们不开心的瞬间
有时候别人做的事会让我们
我们可能会往心里边
默默的积累这种怨恨
甚至对某些人
产生这种强烈的情绪反应
可是这样的怨恨
到底对我们有什么样的好处呢
事实上我想告诉大家
怨恨并不会让我们变得更加的强大
反而会让我们的内心越来越沉重
那么如何化解这些怨恨
走出这种困境呢
欢迎来到
松明讲心理
其实化解怨恨只有一种方法
首先你看在生活当中
很多的事本身它并没有绝对的意义
因为事情的意义
往往是由我们自己赋予的
我举个简单的例子
我们常常会觉得自己受到了伤害
有时候可能是因为他人的言行不当
或者是自己处于一个不公平的境地
你比方说有人让你受伤了
你可能会发脾气
会愤怒他为什么要这样对我
但问题是
受伤这件事本身并没有固有的意义
它的意义是你自己加上去的
你可以把它想象成一种运动
你比方说你很久没有去打网球
一旦重新打起来
肯定会觉得腰酸背痛
你是不是会生气啊
为什么要去打网球
为什么搞得自己这么累
但实际上你要知道
打网球本身并没有错
它只是一个普通的活动
唯一的原因是因为你已经很久没打了
你身体不适应
你才会觉得痛苦
那么你看生活中的某些伤痛
也许就是因为我们不习惯
我们无法适应
甚至因为我们对某些事物
有着过高的这么一个期待
你才会感到那么强烈的不满
我再给大家举一个例子
比方说你和你的朋友
同事或者领导发生了这种冲突
某个人说了一句让你伤心的话
你可能会觉得他故意伤害我
他心里坏
骨子里边就是个坏蛋
想否定我
可是当时
你真的能够确定这个人心里是黑的
是真的能够确定他说那句话的动机
就是想伤害你吗
有没有可能
是因为那个人可能一时情绪不好呢
或者根本没有意识到他自己的话
让你这么的不开心呢
你比方说
可能你的领导说了一句话
让你特别的伤心
你做的不够好
如果你当时就觉得领导心里边很坏
他心很黑
那你就可能会陷入到
愤怒和委屈的情绪里边
甚至影响你对未来工作的态度
但是你有没有想过
领导说那句话的背后
有没有可能是想让你看到
自己还有提升的空间呢
想帮助你进步呢
也许他根本没有恶意
而我们经常因为自己的情绪
而误解别人
甚至自己给某些言行加上负面的意义
导致我们的心情被这份怨恨拖垮
所以你永远不能够完全知道
别人的心意和动机
除非他明确的告诉了你
但是你能做的
是决定你自己
如何去解读他们的话和行为
当你把这句话
理解成一种对自己成长的提醒
而不是攻击
那我告诉你
你的心态就会发生变化
你的情绪也会变得更加的平和
所以大家记住
不要让怨恨控制你的人生
有时候我们总是习惯性的
将所有的不好归咎于别人
认为是别人让自己受伤
导致自己生活不如意
你比方说
你可能因为某一个人的话
感到特别的伤心
认为自己受到了不公平的对待
于是开始恨那个伤害你的人
恨的情绪
它就像一块沉重的石头
压在你的心里边
影响着你对生活的态度
甚至会影响到你的健康
但问题是
别人说的那句话
背后的动机是什么?
你也无法改变过去发生的事
而你能做的
就是你决定如何看待这些事
如何让这些事情
对你的未来能够产生积极的影响
你可以选择
让这段经历成为你成长的动力啊
而不是说让他成为你心中的阴影
永远困扰你
生活中发生的每一件事
不管是让你开心还是让你伤心的
都可以成为你未来生活的铺路石
如果说
你能从这段经历当中学到一些东西
能够从中获得成长
那我告诉你这段事情的意义
他就变得不一样了
我们活着
不是为了去纠结过去的痛苦
而是为了创造一个更加轻松满足
成功和快乐的未来呀
那么如何化解怨恨呢
方法只有一个
恩
感恩
让我们从过往的痛苦里边能够走出来
让我们看到
那些曾经让我们受伤的事情的背后
潜藏的成长机会
感恩并不是让你去忽视
别人给你带来的伤害啊
而是让你学会从这些伤害里边
提炼出有意义的经验
从而让自己变得更加的坚强和智慧
每一次痛苦的经历
都是一次成长的机会
感恩让我们学会放下
让我们从中吸取教训
改正自己的不足
进而让自己的人生变得更加的精彩
感恩不仅能让我们释放怨恨
也能让我们的人生更加的积极向上
那么最后送给大家一句话
而感恩则是让你放下过去
轻松迎接未来的钥匙
心意
你永远都无法证明
感
怨恨只会让你背负沉重的包袱
动机